how's it going bros my pack today we're
gonna check out three games and we're
gonna have him at a good time welcome to
Paco parking simulator which if card
stands for parking all conniving ovaries
where this cart that did something bad
and now everyone wants to [ __ ] kill
us and [ __ ] but I have a secret tactic
that was not that secret tactic don't
judge alright so if you're ever in a
cemetery don't do that haha there's not
much park parking in this park simulator
game in fact you I don't even think you
can park in this game I think that's the
problem of the driver and there's our
baits part with every zombies there are
zombies of course of course why would
there be zombies I got my green
gravedigger car and I'm about to [ __ ] I
was at busted I [ __ ] died at least be
honest with me
you died a horrible death you might as
well put that [ __ ] on there twerk it
twerk it
Oh goddess Ambe where did it cop is this
the Breaking Bad bus Heisenberg you in
there mate the cops are coming after me
oh [ __ ] I better do you see ya oh my god
that was amazing
I was aimed from one direction was here
to see that he would have said that was
amazing no I'm a Zane get it you don't
get it it's fine
hey yo [ __ ] make a u-turn [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
damn it Jesse Jesse Jesse there's my
stop [ __ ] whoo cops can't get dis
card kids get this maybe they can what
am I gonna do about it is this square
what that's so cute
oh my god I'm driving the McDonough's
car I will deliver somebody's nuggets
after the last thing I'll do what what
what are you [ __ ] kidding me
okay sure why not what did I do in a
[ __ ] tricycle to get a [ __ ] tank
after me
alright this time it would work Yolo to
the holo to the brolo goddamn there's
tanks everywhere oh [ __ ] my eyes out why
do I keep saying that's disgusting what
the [ __ ]
look at me now [ __ ] you thought my
YouTube channel would an oh [ __ ] are
never you like my hair so Sugoi all I
wanted to do was deliver its chicken
nuggets to senpai it's that too much to
ask what you gonna do about sent by what
you're gonna do about senpai
what you gotta do about sampai what you
gotta do about set by [ __ ] up that's
that's my new song it's called what
you're gonna do about senpai [ __ ] take
a bite now [ __ ] we're pulling unicorn
senpai slap soakaway Oh God I will never
notice you I'll notice whoever I want to
notice that's right
Sugoi kawaii [ __ ] yeah yeah you like it
you dirty [ __ ] best gameplay ever beats
call of duty
why does not all game developers just
add this in their game I never enjoyed a
game so much you might tell if I had the
weirdest boner right now Wow I'll never
notice you I don't care if you explode
and clone yourself what the [ __ ]
this is the dumbest and best game I have
ever played in my life ah the climax III
I can't explain how it's like to play
this game Bros you just have to try it
out yourself it feels like slapping a
giant dildo that looks like a unicorn in
space with kawaii
Sugoi Japanese music playing in the
background there we go oh my god I'm
sorry bro I can't I don't know it's
pretty okay I guess ten out of ten i gen
on the spirit of halloween we're gonna
play another horror game it's called
poltergeist can you guess what this game
is about it's about being a poltergeist
you didn't guess it so we have this
lovely family they just moved in the
house we have this man with mustache who
won't show me his mustache show me a
massage that's right
this woman's hat is
not fashionable leather-clad
alright thus poodle and thus lady is it
house go back shelf go lap poor dog
don't care don't care at all no what
happened
are you so cure I couldn't possibly be
scared
whoa let them the lamp sit the floor
like the lamp set the floor like that
[ __ ]
oh no Gunter go and joy what are you
doing go ja don't spook them too much
good ja I don't shoot Gunther in the
balls come on that's the oldest trick in
the book now let I'm an evil mastermind
don't they look like one don't I look
like an evil mastermind No well what do
you know about a six even shut up
alright we got some cool new stuff now
we have this Oh God
J says what ghostbusters what are you
doing in here
who are you gonna call if you want to
get rid of a Ghostbusters what is this
oh god I bet you
yeah that's scared yet in yet yeah what
are you gonna do about the flying
lunchbox huh [ __ ]
alright that's all the time I had for
today I hope you enjoyed watching if you
did go ahead and hit that like button
your support and Guerra and my hair to
be fabulous as always and that's all I
have to say stay awesome bros